[MUSIC PLAYING]
LINDSEY: Hello.
So for anyone who doesn't
know me, my name is Lindsey.
And besides being a very proud
Googler, I'm also a wife.
My husband's here today.
I am a mother to two
adorable children.
And I am also a humanitarian.
And up until about
two weeks ago,
I never would have
described myself that way.
Yes, I donate every year and
I participate in Google Serve,
but I never felt
like I was doing
enough to make a difference in
the world to use that label.
But then about two
weeks ago, I was
at a conference with
about 400 other Googlers,
and somebody there actually
read us the definition
of what a humanitarian
was, so I'm going
to read that to you today.
A person who seeks to
promote human welfare.
A person looking to promote
the health, happiness,
and fortunes of a person.
A person looking to promote
the basic physical and material
well-being of people in need.
Now, none of you would
be here today with us
live or joining us
over live stream,
if you, too, weren't
humanitarians,
so I want to thank you for
coming today, taking time out
of your day to discuss
how we together
as a group of humanitarians
can work together
to combat human trafficking.
Now, it was about a
year ago that I first
learned about Willow.
Up until then, I knew that
human trafficking was an issue,
but it always felt too dark.
It felt too disturbing to think
about, much less talk about.
Not exactly a dinner
party conversation,
I think we can agree.
But it was during
a two-hour lunch
that I had with
my dear friend Kim
that day when I realized
that because it's dark
and because it's disturbing
is exactly why we
need to be talking about it.
During that lunch,
she shared with me
the amazing work that
Willow was doing and shared
these incredible stories about
the strength and the resilience
of the survivors.
So here I am today
talking about it,
hosting my first talk at Google.
So on to our incredible
speakers here.
We are lucky to have with
us today Kelsey Galaway,
the founder and
executive director
of Willow International.
Kelsey lived in Uganda
from 2010 to 2015,
where she worked in the
anti-trafficking effort just
out of college.
And while there, she founded
Willow, an organization
that provides aftercare
programs for survivors
and is dedicated
to the prevention
of human trafficking.
She founded Willow to provide
aftercare services that
would keep victims from
getting re-trafficked
and, ultimately, to eradicate
the global epidemic.
She holds a bachelor or arts
degree in international studies
from the University
of California, Irvine,
and is currently
obtaining her PhD.
And we're also joined by Shannon
Rogers, who started Change
a Path, which is a donor circle
that is focused on supporting
anti-trafficking
initiatives domestically
and internationally.
They are fully
volunteer run, have
about 70 members with
varying levels of involvement
and giving, and
they expect to be
granting out $300,000 to
grassroots efforts this year.
So I will let Kelsey and
Shannon take it away.
KELSEY GALAWAY: Awesome.
Thank you, Lindsey.
And thank all of
you for taking time
out your day to be
here to talk to us
about this important issue.
Like Lindsey said, it is
really dark and a lot of people
shy away from learning about
it, from talking about it.
When she said it's not
dinner conversation,
that's true unless
you're Shannon and I,
and this is all of our
dinner conversations
talking about human trafficking.
So thank you.
It means a lot to us.
So we're going to get into it
with a brief overview of what
human trafficking
is because we all
enter this conversation with
a vast understanding of what
the issue is.
Human trafficking, simply
put, is modern-day slavery,
but it's not a simple issue.
It's a really complex
criminal industry.
And it's human
beings profiting off
of the exploitation
of other human beings
through a variety of
different exploitations,
including forced labor and
commercial sexual abuse
among other things.
It is the third largest and
fastest growing criminal
industry in the world.
It's a huge thing to take in.
And if we think about it,
the reason it's fast growing,
the reason it's about to
surpass drug trafficking or arms
trafficking is because
human beings are
a reusable commodity, sadly.
Unlike drugs, which can be
sold once and used once,
human beings can be
sold multiple times
and profited off
of multiple times.
There are over 40 million
victims of trafficking
worldwide.
It's a huge number.
Hard to grasp what
that looks like,
but it's more than
the entire population
of the state of California
living in slavery.
It's also a huge industry, with
profits of over $150 billion
annually, which is more
than Apple, Samsung, BP,
Exxon, and Microsoft combined.
It's out of control.
And one in four
victims is a child.
So why is it growing
so fast and where?
Simply put, trafficking
is an exploitation
of vulnerable people, so
trafficking happens everywhere.
But primarily, it
grows and it thrives
in places where you
have populations
with high vulnerability.
And the International
Labor Organization
reported last year,
that the region
in the world with the
highest prevalence is Africa.
And my experience
is that that also
is the region with the least
amount of organizations
and people working to combat it.
Another reason it's
growing is that traffickers
are acting with impunity.
There is no fear
of being caught.
There's no fear
of being punished.
And as John Cotton
Richmond, who's
about to be the US
Ambassador for Trafficking
always tells me,
traffickers are more
likely to be struck by lightning
than convicted of trafficking.
So we're not dedicating enough
resources to fighting it,
and traffickers are able to
traffic people with really
no fear of being caught.
We work in Uganda.
And Uganda is in east Africa.
And it is a global hub
for human trafficking.
It is a source, a destination,
and a transit country.
And what that means is
that people are trafficked
into Uganda, through
Uganda, and Ugandans
are trafficked from Uganda
all over the world--
far off places like the United
Arab Emirates, Thailand,
Malaysia, and China.
So it's a huge issue.
And it's human beings
doing horrible things
to other people.
But the hopeful part of this
is that human beings can also
do amazing things to work
together to stop this
and to protect
vulnerable people.
And that is what Willow
has set out to do.
And we do that
through collaboration,
which we'll get into.
Our mission is to end
human trafficking,
and that's a big mission.
We are doing that
through prevention,
providing restorative
care to survivors,
and partnering with
governments, nonprofits,
and international agencies.
So we have a short
video, we're going
to share with you that explains
our work in greater detail.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- It's so challenging to
our psyches as human beings
that there are still
today in 2018 people
enslaving, and
abusing, and torturing
other human beings for profit.
People get comfortable in
the world in which they live,
and hearing about that
can be overwhelming.
And so they tend to
stay away from it.
- I think people have
an innate desire for it
not to be true, that people
are enslaving human beings.
We get asked the
prevalence question
all the time, how
big is the problem?
How big is the problem?
And I think what
belies that question
is a disbelief in
the magnitude of it.
- The International
Labor Organization
estimates that
traffickers annually
rake in over $150 billion
a year in profits.
That's more than the
annual profits of Exxon,
Samsung, Apple, and BP combined.
Trafficking is big business.
- 92% percent or 93%
of all trafficking
is happening in the
developing world.
- Uganda is one of the most
stable countries in East
Africa, and it's poised, I
believe, to become a regional,
if not continental leader in
the anti-trafficking fight.
- Willow International
partners with organizations
and governments
all over the world
to coordinate the rescue of
victims of human trafficking.
We get referrals from
government agencies,
international agencies,
and other nonprofits
who work on the
ground in countries
to ensure that victims are
rescued from situations
of trafficking, taken
back home, and given
the services that they need
to heal and be reintegrated
with families.
By focusing our efforts here,
we are leveraging resources
and impact to create
change on the global issue
of human trafficking.
In Uganda, we formed a coalition
of nonprofit organizations
so that each organization
could focus on their expertise
and have the greatest
collective impact.
- The reason that
we need coalitions
to decimate this
problem is that then we
get multiple views of
what the problem is.
Any one organization
is only going
to ever see one
piece of the problem
and is only going to
be able to respond
in one aspect of the solution.
And if you get everybody
around the table,
you start seeing
aspects of the problem
that you never saw before.
So this complex issue requires
a very diverse and multi-sector
response.
- And it's about
relationships, so
that the governmental and the
nongovernmental organizations
work together.
Police, prosecutors, and
victim service providers,
as well-- have them
all partner together
and come to training together
so that they can then
become a team.
They have different functions
and different roles,
but they all have the
same goal, and that's
the rescue of
enslaved human beings
and the conviction of people
who are doing the enslaving.
- We provide therapeutic
aftercare services
to victims of human trafficking.
And what this looks
like is holistic care--
access to health care,
residential services,
psychosocial support
through counseling,
reintegration
services with family,
and help getting
back on their feet,
whether that's through an
educational scholarship, access
to a job, or provision of
capital to start up a business.
And our programs work.
The survivors, despite all
that they have gone through,
send their kids to school,
buy their own houses,
get full-time jobs, or
start their own businesses
and go on to lead
full, healthy lives.
- During the last 15 years that
I've been working full time
in the human trafficking
space, I have seen a lot
of service-providing
nonprofit organizations,
and there are few that I have
been impressed with as much
as Willow.
I have been to Willow's sites.
I have seen their facilities.
I have met the individuals
that work there
and the individuals
whom they care for.
It is amazing.
It is a place of hope.
It is a place of joy.
It is a place of healing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
KELSEY GALAWAY: So
as the video showed,
we have a model
that we have seen
is successful in ending
trafficking, spreading
awareness, preventing
the crime, and providing
restorative care to those who
have been victimized by it.
And as you see in
the diagram, what
holds rescue restoration
and reform together
is collaboration
because no organization,
no government can do all
of these things perfectly.
And so we have to
learn from one another
and be more collaborative,
more integrated
than the traffickers who
are thriving in this crime
right now.
Restoration is how I got into
this work in the first place,
working directly with
survivors of trafficking.
And it is amazing to see the
resiliency and the strength
of people who have been
through the unimaginable.
And our aftercare homes
are places of joy,
and love, and hope,
and we just wanted
to show you a couple of
photos of what it's like.
This is one of our
homes in Uganda.
Right now, 15 women live there
with their young children
receiving all of the
services that they
need to heal and recover from
what they've been through.
This month, we're having a
huge graduation ceremony,
where women who have
been in our program
will be reintegrating
back into community
and families and survivors
from past graduating classes
will be coming back to share
their stories of where they are
now, how they're
doing, and support
other survivors in the program.
So it's a real
family environment.
The survivor you saw in the
video was an adult woman.
And we can't show videos of
the children in our program,
but this isn't just adult
women who are being trafficked.
The people in our program are
as young as two years old,
so this is happening to
very, very young children.
One of the things that many
of our donors and supporters
find really important
is the impact
that their dollar can have
in the developing world.
The average cost of a year of
therapeutic aftercare in the US
is $172,000.
And sadly, recidivism rate,
so being re-trafficked--
the estimates are
70% of victims who
are rescued are
re-trafficked at least once.
So that is a lot of money
going into these programs.
Our organization-- the average
cost of a year of aftercare
is only $6,000 and we
have a 95% success rate
in preventing
revictimization for those who
have gone through our program.
One of the things that excites
me the most about our work
is the reform.
So when I got into
this work and started
by providing aftercare,
what kept me up at night
was that the organization
I was working for
wasn't doing anything
to stop the flow.
We weren't cutting
off the pipeline.
We were getting referrals
from community members who
were identifying girls
who had been trafficked,
but nothing was happening
to the traffickers.
And when you work in a community
filled with vulnerable people,
it's just a sea of
vulnerable people
for traffickers to
bring into that spot
where the one girl was
rescued was working.
And so when I
founded Willow, this
was one of the most
important things
that I wanted to work
on, was figuring out,
how do we stop the flow?
How do we change the system
so that victims are protected
and that traffickers
are prosecuted?
And we have been very
successful with that.
The chief justice who
you saw in the video
through our advocacy
efforts shared
that he wants
combating trafficking
to be a part of his
legacy, and he's
taking steps to do so,
designating prosecutors
to fight trafficking.
They are forming a
specialized unit in Uganda
to combat trafficking.
So it's amazing to see
with a little bit of work
and having a collaborative
spirit the impact you
can have on an entire nation.
And it's super cost effective.
This is just conversations,
knocking on doors,
asking people to
use their resources
and their influence to protect
other vulnerable people.
And collaboration
is key in this.
And Shannon and I were
just talking on the way
over about what
collaboration means to us.
And she asked me, what
does this mean to you?
And collaboration means to me
having the humility to know
that you don't know everything
and the value of learning,
wanting to learn and
connect with other people
who have been in
the field longer
or have various expertise that
could help you reach a shared
vision.
And this is a map of
our global footprint.
You can see that although
Uganda is a country of only 30
million people, we have
a huge network that
consists of rescue
organizations, governments,
international agencies who
are all working together
to combat trafficking,
whether that's
preventing it, prosecuting
traffickers, reforming
criminal justice systems,
or ensuring that victims
are rescued and brought home.
And as the famous
Helen Sworn says,
"a networked problem requires
a networked solution."
And traffickers are networked.
They figure out in Uganda how to
get a girl from a rural village
to the city's capital
onto a plane with a visa
and vaccination forged
documents to get to Thailand.
All of that is done through
collaborative efforts
of a lot of people.
So if we want to
combat this, we need
to be more collaborative, more
networked then the traffickers.
And collaboration can
feel like a fluffy word,
but it's really
not a fluffy thing.
Some of our-- to give
you some examples
of what collaboration
looks like for us,
we have rescue
partners in Thailand.
So we connect with organizations
who work with the Thai police
and Thai government to identify
victims of trafficking,
get them out of those
situations, and send them home.
So one of those
organizations is NightLight.
And this year, I
would imagine they've
sent around 20, 25
Ugandan victims who
have been trafficked to Thailand
back to Uganda to receive
restorative care and
be reintegrated back
into communities.
However, we don't
just stop there.
Through our partners in
these other countries,
we say, hey, how can we
have a bigger impact?
We see this pipeline of Ugandans
being trafficked to Thailand.
What can we do to stop it?
And so we both approached
the Thai government
and the Ugandan government
and said, how can we
support you in combating this?
And they said,
let's set up a call.
And so what we did
in Uganda, we went
to one of our pro bono lawyer
partners and said, hey,
can you donate a
conference room to us?
We had a Skype call where we
had the Ugandan prosecutor
for human trafficking, the
lead criminal investigator
for human trafficking, and the
human trafficking task force
coordinator on a Skype call
with the Thai government,
where they developed
solutions together
to have they could stop
this trafficking syndicate.
They're now developing a mutual
legal assistance agreement,
where they will start
sharing evidence
to prosecute these traffickers
and stop the global syndicate.
So it's amazing
how simple that is.
When you just get people
in a room and say, hey,
how can we collaborate
to stop this thing?
I believe that
through this, we're
going to see the pipeline
into Thailand from Uganda
be shut down.
And it really cost us no
more than the salaries
of the staff who are
working on this project.
We also partner with academia.
So last year, we
did a research on,
how do we prevent trafficking?
What do these communities
know about trafficking?
What are their
attitudes towards it?
And how do we stop it?
And that was done
with Yale Law School.
We also partner with Pepperdine
University Law School's Global
Justice program.
And through that, we've trained
150 judges on the Ugandan
trafficking law and we educated
150 key government members
on what trafficking was.
And that's opened
up this floodgate
of the Ugandan
government's involvement
in wanting to make stopping
trafficking a priority.
The other thing that
we believe is really
important with collaboration
is collaborating
with people, donors who want
to dedicate their resources.
They may not want to quit
their day job to stop and join
a nonprofit or join the
government to stop trafficking,
but they're passionate about it.
They want to learn.
They want to get involved.
And financial support is a
way that they can do that.
And I think that that
is a key component
that nonprofit organizations
need to focus on,
is how do we bring
people who have a heart
to do this into the work?
And that is where
Shannon comes in.
And she has created a
really innovative model
for how donors can
help join the fight
to combat human trafficking.
She's going to
take it from here.
SHANNON ROGERS: Hi.
Thanks so much for
having us here.
This is just awesome.
It's awesome that you guys
are showing this interest.
And it's, as Kelsey was
saying, this issue's huge,
and it's heavy.
And I often am saying to
our members and donors
because I know they can come
to some of our gatherings
and feel that weight, when
you're out in the field
and you're meeting all these
people that are actually
implementing solutions, and
driving change, and doing it,
the weight sort of starts
to spread and go away
because there are some
amazing people out there doing
amazing work.
And I'm appreciative that
Google is taking the time
to highlight
somebody like Kelsey
and what she's doing
with Willow because they
are one of those
organizations that
are truly doing amazing work
in addressing this big issue.
So I do run Change a Path.
We're a donor circle
that is focused
on supporting
anti-trafficking initiatives,
really supporting grassroots
organizations in their work
to address these issues.
And we do have about 70
members, like you said earlier.
But the 70 members that are
involved in their varying ways.
And as you can imagine, in
running a grant making program,
having 70 members be
involved in those decisions
would not be very
fun or effective.
It would be quite
frustrating, actually.
So we have a committee of five
that does all of our vetting.
And a big part of our
vetting is really--
we've developed our process.
This past year, we gave to 10
organizations about $300,000.
We've funded 14
different organizations
over the last three years.
And we consider our grantees
partners in this work
because we view this
as collaborative work.
We think this is so
important to bring everybody,
all the stakeholders
to the table
to get people working together.
And to me, it's
a huge compliment
that Kelsey asked me to be
up here with her presenting
on this because some
organizations do not
think of funders as partners.
But the reality
is, funders really
do need to be partners in
this because to be funding
effectively, to be
funding well, you
need to be doing
a lot of research.
You need to do all the learning
that Kelsey is talking about.
So we spend a lot of time.
So we have our processes,
we have our criteria.
But most of our time is
truly spent on learning.
It's meeting organizations,
meeting many people
in the space and in the
industry doing different things,
going to conferences.
I had the good
fortune to meet Kelsey
at a conference in Bangkok.
And it was like a dream for
me because all of a sudden I'm
having dinner with Kelsey,
a woman from Bangkok working
in Bangkok to address
the issues there,
a woman in Guangzhou to
address the issues in China.
And they're all
talking about how
to best support
each other, how they
deal with different situations.
There's so much learning
that needs to happen,
and we need to provide
platforms and opportunities
to share all that learning.
And as a funder, we
feel like sharing
that learning is an
important role in what we do.
And when I say, that it's not
about talking to organizations
or grantees and telling
them what they need to do
or what the best
way is, it truly
starts from a point
of listening to them.
What are their needs?
What are their challenges?
What do they want support with?
It's not about telling
them, you should do this.
It's about, how do
we best help you?
And then I can help connect
you to other resources,
to other people doing this
work, or other models.
When Kelsey started talking
about her prevention program,
we were able to talk about
some programs in India
that were doing similar
work, and maybe she'd
want to go read about them.
That kind of shared
learning is what's
so critical to
helping organizations
work in their communities,
but also moving
the whole anti-trafficking
movement forward.
We have a long way to go.
We've learned a lot, but
there's a long way to go
and a lot of support needed.
And there's best
practices out there.
There's great-- the
research piece is really
picking up in a lot of ways.
So as a donor, it's about
funding that collaboration,
funding the new initiatives,
the new ways of doing things,
and exploring different
opportunities.
So we truly believe
that collectively we
need to do this, and it's about
helping our grantees and even
the organizations that
we're not funding,
but we work with
closely, helping
them expand their network
because the network
piece is critical.
So it's all about learning.
It's about networking.
It's about doing
this collectively
and collaboratively.
So sorry, I can ramble.
So I think the
amazing thing I want
to highlight about Willow--
and so when we are looking
at organizations to fund,
I think, and Kelsey has a
very collaborative approach
to doing this.
But one of the amazing
things about that
is what she's doing-- she
gave a couple examples.
She basically is just
knocking on people's doors.
She's asking the questions.
She's getting out there
and pulling other people
into the conversation.
So when you're talking to
different organizations
or learning about different
organizations in this space,
if they think what they're
doing is the only way
to do it or the best
way, it's a big red flag
because these issues are so
complex and so integrated
into our culture, whether it's
in the US, or Uganda, Bangkok,
anywhere--
it's happening everywhere.
We need to be out
knocking on doors.
We need to be
engaging more people
and talking to more
about possible solutions.
And we need to be investing
in different solutions.
So thank you.
KELSEY GALAWAY:
Shannon, could you
share a bit about why you
chose a collaborative model
for funding?
SHANNON ROGERS: You mean, in
having it be a donor circle?
KELSEY GALAWAY: Mm-hm.
SHANNON ROGERS: Yeah.
You know, I was first
exposed to a donor circle
when I was living in Hong Kong.
And it was such a brilliant
form of philanthropy
because it engaged people
at the level at which they
wanted to engage.
And you end up pooling your
money together and granting it
out in thoughtful,
creative ways,
and fully vet it so where
your money is going.
I think it so
impressed me because it
was so efficient,
and so effective,
and it was collaborative,
and there was a community.
You could create a
community around it.
And when I moved
back to the US, I
wanted to do something similar.
And then I got hit
really hard by the fact
that you're asked for
money all the time.
Like, if you have
children in schools,
you're asked all the time.
And they're in different
clubs or different sports,
you're asked all the time.
So I sort of went back a
bit and said, oh, I don't I
don't want to be another ask.
I don't want to be
involved in that.
But then I realized
that it's such a missed
opportunity for engagement.
And especially when it comes
to something like trafficking,
which was a very strong
interest of mine,
and I had been
supporting organizations
in Asia addressing these issues.
But it just sort of--
it was the perfect model to
be addressing those issues
because it's about
educating more people
and engaging more people,
while at the same time,
doing it thoughtfully
and effectively,
if that is an answer
to your question.
Because as a community, as
Change a Path has grown,
we have events, and engage
more and more people
in talking about the
solutions, and really building
on our knowledge base.
And it's been an impactful
organization in that way,
and creating that community.
KELSEY GALAWAY: Yeah.
We'll open it up
to questions now.
SHANNON ROGERS: I should
sit on my hands, I think.
AUDIENCE: Thanks so
much for sharing.
I'm really curious
about the houses
that you have for everyone to
have this safe place to be.
How do you really ensure that
the survivors are staying safe
and that these locations,
which seem to be a safe haven,
but that could also be a target
if people know that this is
a place where people
can be re-trafficked
or stuff like that, so how do
you keep these centers safe?
KELSEY GALAWAY: Yeah,
well one of the--
in establishing
safety for anyone,
having clear boundaries
and expectations
is super important.
So when any survivor
comes into our program,
they have a case
manager who briefs them
through an orientation.
These are the
rules of the house.
These are the rules
of the program.
This is how we keep you safe.
This is when the gate closes.
This is when you
need to be indoors.
So we have clear protocols
for safety for each house,
depending on if it's children,
adults, adults with children.
We also have 24/7 security.
And so two of our
homes right now
have armed police because of
the severity of the situation.
So if we get a referral
from the government of cases
and we assess it
as a high risk, we
ask for police guards
to be on the property.
And they are highly
trained, very professional.
We have a really good working
relationship with the police
that we work with
because they give us
the highly-trained
people who understand
working in protecting children.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for giving
your presentation--
very interesting.
I was wondering with
regards to corroboration,
what is it that companies
like YouTube or Google can do?
Do these victims
ever have access
to internet whilst they
are being trafficked?
Are there any touch points
with any of our products?
KELSEY GALAWAY: I know
that Google is doing a lot
to fight human trafficking.
They have helped
fund and collaborate
to start help lines.
I know that they
work with Polaris,
which is the national
hotline here in the US,
which is a super easy number.
If you do see a victim of
trafficking, look up Polaris,
and that's the number
that you can call.
You can even text.
So Google is doing
a lot to do this.
And I think they do it in a
way that's very thoughtful.
I always call Shannon
a thoughtful donor
because she researches.
She tries to understand the
needs of the organizations
in the movement.
And from what I know about
Google, they're doing the same.
They're doing this
work very thoughtfully
and partnering
with organizations
who are doing it really well.
I think where we could step it
up is just more people getting
involved, and more
employees at Google saying,
this is really important to me.
Let's give more money.
Let's do more projects.
And then, having really
long conversations,
strategy sessions
with organizations,
asking what those needs are
because the needs really do
need to be contextualized for
the region, the demographic,
the type of
trafficking that it is.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'd like to know what life
can be like after slavery
for these women.
KELSEY GALAWAY: Yeah,
that's a great question.
Most people who come to
our aftercare programs
are really shocked by what
they see because they're not
expecting the joy
and the laughter that
exists in our aftercare home.
So it is incredibly
difficult to heal
from the trauma of trafficking.
It really is.
But what the survivors
in our program
often tell us is that what's
even more difficult to heal
from is the vulnerabilities
and the exploitation
that led up to them being
trafficked-- broken family
relationships,
previous sexual abuse.
But through therapy,
through counseling,
through being in a
loving environment, where
you are supported and
loved just as you are,
through building a
social support network--
one of the other
programs we have
is a survivor support group.
So we facilitate
this, where they
can come together and
share how they've coped,
managing triggers,
reintegrating back into society.
That's been one of
their favorite programs,
that when we ask, what's
working, they say,
survivor support
group is amazing.
So life after trafficking,
yes, it's difficult.
Yes, it's a painful
thing to heal from.
But there is so much hope.
There is so much
restoration possible.
And gosh, these people we work
with are incredibly resilient.
Many of them have gone on to
even work for the organization
or become advocates
for the cause.
When we had the first
trafficking conference
in Uganda, six
survivors were on stage
and shared their stories because
they said, this happened to us,
and we never want this to
happen to another human being.
That's why we're
sharing our story.
Even though it's painful,
they become advocates
and want to protect
other people.
AUDIENCE: Thank you guys so much
for sharing everything with us.
I'd love to know
more, just about
the experience of these
people in the center.
How long do they usually stay?
And also, are you guys
usually at capacity?
Are you like turning
away referrals?
Do you sort of help
them find jobs?
Just more details about that
would be super interesting.
KELSEY GALAWAY: Yeah,
our programs are all--
we do individualized
case management,
which is a long way of saying
that every survivor who
comes into our program
creates an individualized case
plan with a social
worker and counselor.
So we don't say, you
have six months to heal
and you're out the door.
It really is contextualized
to the individual's needs.
It looks at their
family of origin.
What was going on before
they were trafficked?
Is it a safe home to
return to, or do we
need to find a distant relative
who has a safe home who's
willing to take
them in, or do we
need to prepare them for
a life of self-sufficiency
and creating a new
community for them?
Other factors are
the level of trauma
that they're experiencing.
So some survivors that we work
with in labor trafficking cases
are actually coming
back so traumatized
that they're non-verbal.
Some of them are unable
to speak or share
what's happened to them.
So those cases might be
with us for a longer period
of time because of
the intense treatment
that's required
to heal from that.
What was the second
part of your question?
SHANNON ROGERS: Employment?
AUDIENCE: Do you have
to turn people away?
KELSEY GALAWAY: Oh, yes.
AUDIENCE: Are you guys
fully at capacity usually?
KELSEY GALAWAY: Yep, so our
residential homes are usually
at capacity, and those are
our restorative safe homes.
It is a constant thing that
we're always fundraising for.
We opened a third home this
year to meet the demand.
But in addition
to opening a home,
we started a community-based
care program.
And this has been really
effective in other countries.
Not every survivor
of trafficking
needs to live in a safe home.
Some women coming back
from other countries
had three or four children
before they were trafficked.
And they just want to get
home, and be with their kids,
and be with their families.
So for those cases, we
provide external services.
So our mobile social work
team either goes to them
to provide the services or we
provide transportation for them
to come to us.
So we've been able to
scale through that program,
but we're constantly fundraising
so that we can meet the demand.
And I know that that's true for
every aftercare organization
that I've ever talked to.
And then, in terms
of employment,
that's a great way to
spotlight collaboration.
We right now have
it an organization
called International Sanctuary.
Shannon's wearing one of--
SHANNON ROGERS:
Necklaces or bracelets.
KELSEY GALAWAY: --jewelry
that they've made.
They employ 20
survivors in our program
full time to make jewelry
and also learn job skills--
getting to work on time,
conflict management.
It's been an incredible
program for our survivors.
Some of them stay in that
job for a couple years.
Some of them get some
start-up capital,
and then start a
business that they
dreamed of doing before
they were trafficked.
So employment is huge.
And it's one of the things
that we rely heavily
for collaboration on.
We are actually traveling
out to Uganda next month
with an organization called
Open Gates International.
And they start culinary
institutes and then
corresponding bakeries
or restaurants
that employ survivors as well.
LINDSEY: I just
want to thank you
so much for taking so much
initiative with this topic
and this organization.
And that's what
collaboration is all about.
And it takes people who take
initiative to make it happen.
So thank you so much for
today and for helping
with everything we do.
SHANNON ROGERS: Thank you.
And that's probably
a good transition
because Google Giving Week
kicks off again in a few weeks.
November 26, I will be
running a campaign for Willow
again this year.
So if anybody wants to
sponsor with me, I'd love it.
Or we're going to get our
donation credit again,
hopefully, this year,
so consider Willow
during that week.
So thank you guys
for being here.
And of course ping me,
email me if you guys
want to get more involved.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]